check out my new car this is a 2009
Corvette and because I'm a wired editor
not only do I get to drive an awesome
car but it's filled with gadgets for
instance I've got a blackberry playbook
in here a blackberry and an iphone and
the car itself has been tricked out with
special hardware and software it's made
by a company called qnx now they make
the software that underlies on star and
a bunch of other in car control systems
this is a demo of some things that you
might see in future cars so here's some
cool things about this car basically
it's running an operating system that
lets it linked up with devices that
you've got in the car with the elec cars
own electronics or even with services
that are out on the internet so there's
a button in the middle here which you
can press to switch the instrument
cluster view between a tachometer or you
can make it display a map or the album
art for whatever music you're currently
playing or you can even view a weather
report if that's what you want to see it
can stream music from a playbook or an
iPhone or the cars own hard drive can
even stream music from pandora out on
the internet if that's what you want if
you plug in an iPhone you can control it
using the multimedia console in the
middle here instead of the iphones own
controls and because this is the same
basic operating system that's used to
power the blackberry playbook you'll
soon be able to run apps much like on
the playbook except on the car or you
can integrate playbook apps with the car
like the climate control system app that
they've got on this playbook here you
can even watch YouTube or play video
games although if you don't have my
cat-like reflexes I would recommend not
doing this while you're driving how much
does all this awesomeness cost well it
depends on the car that it's built into
it's an option but I will say it's
available in some pretty cheap Chevy's
so you don't necessarily have to have a
in Corvette like me
you